nos preguntan qué número falta bueno
vemos todos estos números y aquí hay un
espacio vacío y aquí continúan números
veamos tenemos 100 101 102 103 104 105
106 107 108 es el número que seguiría
aquí y después del 108 by 109 y el 110
aquí va 108 comprobamos respuesta
veamos este otro ejercicio nos preguntan
bien número falta y aquí vemos este
cuadro que tiene cuadritos con números
pero nos encontramos que este cuadrito
no tiene un número ese es el número que
falta cual es bueno tengo que ver cuáles
son los números que están antes de este
y cuáles son los que están después
veamos antes de este cuadrito voy a irme
por acá
95 96 97 98 y del 98 sigue 99 y después
del 99 sigue el 100 así que aquí va a un
99 lo escribimos
comprobamos respuestas
es correcta vamos a la siguiente
pregunta nuevamente es un ejercicio
parecido al que hicimos anteriormente
pero ahora el cuadrito que falta o el
número que falta con el cuadrito vacío
es este vamos a ver los números que
están antes y los números que están
después más vamos a regresar nos por
aquí aquí tenemos 115 luego sigue 116
117 118 119 y después del 119 va el 120
así que aquí va un 119 vamos a
escribirlo comprobamos respuesta
es correcto vamos a hacer otra pregunta
más quién número va justo antes del 100
nos piden el número que está antes de
llegar a 100 vamos a regresar nos un
poquito como al 95 vamos a contar a
partir del 95 95 96 97 98 99 100 99 es
el número que está justo antes del 100
escribimos aquí 99 y vamos a comprobar
la respuesta
es correcta una pregunta más parecida a
la anterior que el número va justo antes
de 105 pues vamos a comenzar a contar
desde 100 100 101 102 103 104 105 el
número que está justo antes de 105 es
104 comprobamos la respuesta
es correcta vamos a hacer uno más que el
número falta aquí tenemos estos números
como el ejemplo del inicio y tenemos que
está bien aquí está un espacio vacío
luego sigue 102 y el 103 104 105 hasta
110 pero que nos falta aquí pues el
número que está antes del 102 es el 101
y el número que está después del 100
el 101 vamos a comprobar la respuesta
es correcta